what happened was she kept questioning
me at her level of analysis and that
just wasn't working because that wasn't
the level of analysis at which i'm
playing and then and well and i'm also
not playing although i'm trying to play
yeah you know what i mean because it's
better if you can play a little bit
but yeah it sounds like wrestling you
had a lower base of gravity mm-hmm and
and i think that that gave you an
advantage well partly i wasn't trying to
win the interview right you know like i
and i don't try to win interviews i try
to go to an interview and have a talk
and have a discussion and see how it
goes and i don't have an agenda except
to not make a catastrophic mistake
that's agenda number one don't say
anything unforgivably stupid
i would say about 700 of you roughly uh
requested for him to be on the show and
for us to sit down i've read a lot about
him lately and jordan welcome to the
show welcome to the reuben report thanks
very much
so thank you for being our google
hangout guinea pig and bearing with us
as we are in between studios this is a
pure
free speech zone that probably makes the
guy like you feel pretty good huh
yeah well you know good that means we
might be able to discuss some things
that are important instead of
pussyfooting around
absolutely so let's get right to it so
for people that don't know your story
what has sort of put you in the news
over the last couple of months uh it's
actually quite astounding because you
are in canada which is a place that has
a strong tradition of free speech so for
people that have no idea what's going on
with you uh can you just lay out the the
basics of what's transpired over the
last couple months
yeah well there's a there's some new
legislation that's pending at the
federal level called bill c-16 and bill
c-16 adds gender identity and gender
expression to the list of protected
categories under the canadian human
rights code canadian human rights act
and
also adds
transgressions against those categories
people who are in those categories
uh to the hate speech provisions of the
criminal code
so it's it's very very punitive
legislation and that in itself is is
is somewhat appalling although it's not
obvious why but
there's similar legislation already in
many provinces in canada
which equivalent to the state level
and uh
the
there's a requirement that that
originated in ontario
for people to use
preferred what their what are called
preferred pronouns to address someone
and as far as i can tell
by reading over the legislation
failure to use someone's preferred
pronouns is now a hate crime in canada
right so let's let let's just pause
there for a second
i want people to really understand what
that means that means that if you
potentially
accidentally refer to someone
as the wrong pronoun you may not realize
if someone happens to be a male or a
female you could potentially be in legal
trouble now that also you could do it
intentionally which i think under free
speech would be fine as well but even
accidentally we're going down a pretty
slippery slope yeah well in the
legislation like
there are legal moves afoot in many
organizations uh at a policy level or a
legal level to also alter the way that
the law is interpreted so that instead
of judging someone on the intent of
their speech you judge them on the
consequences of their speech
and also
um
to
to and this is particularly true say
with sexual harassment policies
to remove and this is happening mostly
at universities right now although it'll
happen in other organizations soon
enough
to remove if you're accused of sexual
harassment or worse
instead of
you presumed innocent until proven
guilty
they use the doctrine of preponderance
of evidence
and so
so not only are there changes afoot
to to regulate the way that people speak
they call that uh
compelled speech the american supreme
court ruled on that at one point and
ruled it unconstitutional that it
contradicted the first amendment that
compelled speech
so but in canada i think these pieces of
legislation are also unconstitutional
but of course no one's yet challenged
them as far as you'd have to challenge
them to prove that which would be all
the way to the supreme court yeah okay
so we're obviously going to focus mostly
on the free speech component of it i
would imagine that there's probably a
few people listening to this that would
say wait a minute wait a minute maybe
this guy just doesn't like transgender
people maybe he just wants to be
offensive to transgender people so i'll
just kick that back to you is that the
case at all well a lot of the people
who've been pushing this legislation
um claim to be speaking for the
transgender community but that's not
self-evident to me at all i've received
many letters of support from
transgendered people and actually just
did a conversation with a transgender
woman
in vancouver most transgendered people
especially the classic type i would say
speaking psychologically are people
who've had
a difficult time adjusting to their
biological sex identity since they were
young and some of them undergo fairly
radical transformations in an attempt to
become the other sex
and they have no problem with pronouns
they just want to be the other one
right yeah that's right they don't have
any problem with he or she in fact they
undergo
a tremendous amount of trouble i would
say to
transform themselves
for better or worse into a member of the
opposite sex um the people who are
pushing this legislation forward claim
to speak for the transgender community
but you can claim to speak for any
community you want that doesn't make you
a legitimate representative right so so
that's a great point and actually the
the girl that you spoke to up in
vancouver we've had on our reuben report
fan show so people can check that out
her name is darren meyer i think she's
an excellent spokesperson for the trans
community uh i don't know that she's
asking to be a spokesman for the trans
community but sometimes people are sort
of just thrust into things um
so okay so in and of itself you have no
problem with trans people right is that
fair to say
well i don't i don't i don't have any
problem with trans people
um i mean i'm a clinical psychologist
i've dealt with every variety of person
you could possibly imagine and a fair
number of people that you couldn't
possibly imagine and i'm i'm
so i'm quite comfortable with people who
don't fit normally into normal
categories and i know how to deal with
people who are in that situation very
well so the idea that i'm doing this
because i'm somehow made nervous by
people who don't fit neatly into gender
categories is it's exactly the sort of
trick that you'd expect people on the
radical left to pull because it's what
they do all the time they call me a
racist too because
the university of toronto human
resources and equity department has been
taking advice from a group called the
black liberation collective
which was formulated by uh two women one
is who one who is a self-avowed black
supremacist who believes that white
people are inferior because they don't
have enough melanin in their skin and
that makes them unable to receive cosmic
energy and transform it into proper
thought
and is that is that what my problem is
that is definitely your problem and the
other one is under investigation for
embezzling 300 000 from the university
of toronto students union
and so and they also
uh will not disavow violence in their
pursuit of social transformation the
university of toronto hr and equity
department is taking policy advice from
them uh which i think is appalling
um
and because i've objected to that i've
been tarred with the epithet of racist
so but it's critical it's it's typical
of this kind of mob behavior that that
the pc authoritarians like to engage in
whenever anybody ruffles their feathers
i've been wrestling with this idea
because i'm going to give some biblical
lectures starting on may 16th and so
i've been starting to think about
conceptualizations of god for example
and one of the things that's very
interesting about the old testament is
that
there's a there's a distinction made
between
countries that rule by the ruler who's
god
and countries that are ruled by god
who's not the ruler
okay so strip it for a minute of its
religious language
and imagine this instead
imagine that what we consider god
is the abstraction of the ideal by which
people have to orient themselves to
produce a functional society
it's an abstraction right so it's just
sort of the the basic underlying truth
of how we
are able to function as a group of
people yes properly and you can't
identify it with any one person because
when you identify it with a person then
the system gets corrupted because the
person gets inflated let's say
this would be like the pharaoh basically
yes exactly like precisely like that
that's exactly that that's the canonical
story in the old testament is the
pharaoh is the earthly ruler who demands
everything that you should provide to
god what's god well we'll we'll can
speak about it from an evolutionary
psychology perspective
god is the idea of the abstract ideal
and you separate it out from
from the actual ruler just like in in in
our society the idea of sovereignty is
abstracted from the president
right the president comes and goes
the sovereignty of the president remains
the sovereignty of the president is a
very abstract idea
because it's disembodied
right it's disembodied now how we were
chimps for god's sake how long do you
think it took us to figure out how to
disembody the idea of sovereignty from
the individual man it was like
well it was it was maybe up until uh
maybe it took us till 150 000 years ago
to start to start formulating that you
know in in some articulated way in some
abstract way i think we could recognize
it before then and the way you recognize
it is through admiration
right if you meet someone that you
admire there's someone you want to
imitate and what it is imagine this
pattern that will move you up the
hierarchy and then you see people who
manifest different elements of it
and you see someone who manifests an
element that you don't have and
something in your response to that with
with admiration it's unconscious right
because it pulls you towards them it's
not voluntary you see that really with
kids a lot when they when they hear a
worship someone and start to imitate
them right you know but but the same
thing happens throughout culture yeah
you could probably make an interesting
argument related to trump with this
because it was like some people i think
subconsciously although somewhat
consciously saw him and they said wow he
says whatever he wants yeah and they
love that and then you could also argue
the reverse some people saw him saying
whatever he wants and they thought this
is this is the end of civilization right
this is this is some monster for
civilization so that does sort of also
go to i guess self deception and how we
all
are viewing things differently
constantly all the time well
there's a bunch of ways that that you
can bias your information intake let's
say
now what should happen is
roughly speaking i guess is that
you have a field of information let's
say it's behavioral information so it's
information that would be relevant to
how you conduct yourself which isn't the
same as factual information
which is another mistake that i think
harris makes
what you want
is an unbiased sample of that you can't
understand all of it because it's too
complex wait let's just back up for a
second just to be clear so the i think
everyone would understand what factual
information is
what's the other part then give me an
example of the other part
the other part is what makes you admire
someone so it's just the it's the innate
feeling sort of well it's it's it's what
you get when you go to a movie
say that that's an animated movie we
talked about that a little bit with
pinocchio for example is that what's
being presented there are descriptions
of patterns of behavior
they're not you they're fact like but
the reason that they're different than
facts is because you can immediately act
them out
you can't act out a fact it's like
so imagine that you're standing in front
of a field
if you adopted harris's point of view as
far as i can tell
the field would tell you how to walk
through it
but it doesn't it offers you an infinite
number of ways to walk through it and
then how you walk through it depends on
your value system it depends on what you
want that's the thing that's where
values enter it you're going to walk
through the field towards your goal
and your goal is something you value and
that's built right into our perception
you can't even look at the world without
a goal because there's too much of the
world and if you don't have a goal then
you don't know what to look at it'll
just be chaotic
or meaningless either one of those two
overwhelming or meaningless and so the
the the value system is built into the
perceptions
now that brings us back to the bias
issues that
when you when you look at a field of
behavioral information let's say or even
factual information for that matter your
temperament is going to screen a lot of
it out for you and that's good because
otherwise you'd be overwhelmed but let's
say you're a person who's not creative
and that generally tends to make people
more conservative
anything that has to do with aesthetics
generally speaking
isn't going to glimmer for you right
it's not going to attract your interest
now if you're an extrovert then social
things are attract your interest and if
you're agreeable person then things
about relationships will attract your
interest if you're disagreeable it's
more likely to be about machines and
things
so but that's all happening before you
think now there's feedback loops of
course but it happens before you think
you're carving out a niche in the world
and there's lots of different ways you
can be in the world so that's one form
of bias and you see this in plenty in
this in the realm of politics because we
know for example that
you can predict people's political
beliefs if you know their temperament
and quite well
so
if people are high in trade openness
which is creativity
creativity and interest in abstract
ideas roughly speaking
and low in conscientiousness especially
orderliness you're going to be a liberal
you're going to lean to the left
you're going to be a liberal but the
politically correct types are different
right right and if you're
low in openness and high in
conscientiousness especially orderly
you're going to be a conservative and
the relationship is actually quite tight
if you just look at how people vote the
relationship isn't that powerful but if
you do a detailed analysis of their
beliefs say conservative versus liberal
the amount
of political belief the temperament
accounts for goes way up compare
yourself to who you were yesterday not
to who someone else is today yeah well
you've got to improve right
and so
and you might think well i'm a real
fixer-upper and i'm really embarrassed
about that because there's 50 things
wrong with me and like look at that guy
and so now i feel all terrible because
of the comparison and all of that and
first of all it's unfair because
especially by the time you're about 30
when you're 17 you're like every other
17 year old and so that kind of social
comparison is more appropriate by the
time you're about 30 your life has
become quite idiosyncratic you know like
let's say your life has eight dimensions
family friends intimate relationships
health you know you can kind of
lay them out
you're
individually
positioned in all those dimensions your
life isn't like anyone else's life and
so you see someone who's doing better
than you it's like you're only seeing
one dimension at one slice of time so
it's not reasonable you know what you
don't have the whole picture
you know
so and then you you get down on yourself
and and take the spirit out of yourself
and you get bitter and resentful it's
like there's nothing good about that
yeah so so but you do need to improve
because there's more to you than there's
not as much of you as there should be so
what's the comparison well that's easy
you just say okay well here here's my
position in time and space right now
here's my
virtues and faults it's like
i can be a little bit better tomorrow in
some minor way
well that's the right comparison because
you are very much like you you know you
know what i mean everything's the same
about you yeah and so it's the perfect
comparison and then you get a trajectory
going it's like well
obviously i'm not perfect but i'm
slightly less terrible than i was
yesterday man you keep that up for
five years
and you're wherever you should be that
isn't where someone else should be right
because you really are an individual
there's an interesting element of this
on on a biblical note that i think you
hit sometimes which is sort of don't
pray to false gods because it's like
it's sort of like well the guy that
you're looking at that you think has
everything yeah you have no idea yeah
right and we see that now with all these
people crumbling in hollywood that are
worshiped by so many people who have
done all sorts of terrible things or
whatever it is yeah well you just don't
have insight into the tragedy of someone
else's life you know and you might think
well he's rich and successful it's like
yeah but you just don't know you don't
know what his relationship is with his
wife or his children you know you don't
know that he's gone through two divorces
and his daughter won't talk to him and
one of his kids is schizophrenic and
like most people's lives are pretty
nicely saturated with tragedy you know
and with a certain degree of malevolence
and you might think well i'd trade
places with him in a minute and i'm also
not saying that some people don't have
it really rough it's like look man some
people have it rough yeah that's not the
point
it's not the point the point is
you should be better than you are but
it's not because you're worse than other
people it's because you're not
everything you should be and so you've
got to pick the comparison right and
then that's also enabling it's like an
instantly hopeful there is absolutely no
doubt that you can be slightly better
tomorrow than you are today
and then
because of the pareto principle that you
know that that movement towards the good
in increases exponentially that
trajectory can just take you out of hell
very very rapidly and so you know
there's nothing but good
about that yeah just quick sidebar
before we get to number five so you
mentioned sort of 17 we're all sort of
at that same you can't have that much
differentiation between the people
around you but 30 it's a little more
calcified do you think there's a cut off
age i don't mean exactly a number like
you're going to say 56 but do you think
that there's a point and there was a
question asked at clemson where somebody
said to you you know you really helped
my 60 year old father who had all this
stuff going wrong in his life he started
listening to you and he said he's i
think she said he's in the best place
he's ever been saying but do you think
that there's a cut off age where just
physiologically
you can't quite well i think it gets
harder because you get more who you are
as you get older you know so there's not
the ratio of actuality to potential
starts to shift
but but it doesn't change the underlying
simple truth which is
there is definitely something that you
can do today
that will make you slightly better
for the next day always
always no let's okay not always you're
85 right you have alzheimer's you know
you're done
sometimes you're done
but most of the time you're not and most
of the time there's something within
your grasp that you could put right
and see that's the fundamental issue
it's like life is tragic
it's full of suffering and it's full of
malevolence there's no doubt about that
and it's it's brutal
and it's more brutal than you can even
imagine in some ways or willing to
imagine
but there's something you could put
right
and we don't know what would happen if
you put everything you could right if
you put it right and then we don't know
what would happen if everyone did that
but you can be certain that it would be
less tragic and less malevolent and so
like you don't have anything better to
do than that right like get get it
it's almost like we're all
frankenstein's monster in a weird way if
the if the mainstream media had been
dealing honestly with the issues of the
day whatever they are identity politics
or post-modernism or just the general
political discussion then i don't think
people would react to you guys the way
that they do because they didn't do
their job but really quickly because you
because you hit these so your mo i think
there are three moments and you already
hit them but just for people that that
aren't following all this
you on piers morgan
basically bashing him endlessly with
facts
over feelings about guns was one where
it was like this guy from the internet
just beat this cnn per person how did
that happen and then i think you know
the one that changed me more than
anything else everyone knows this
already was sam harris on real time with
with affleck and they got into this
stuff about about the difference between
muslims and islam i didn't even know who
sam was i see this mild-mannered
neuroscientist in a nice suit calmly
talking about pew statistics next thing
you know he's gross and racist but but
this is a good segue to yours because i
think yours is the third one and the way
that this is just two or three weeks ago
uh you were on with kathy newman on it's
canada channel four no it was uk uk
channel four sorry
and there there's i mean everyone that's
watching this has probably seen this
already
uh you haven't you should go watch it
yeah and if you haven't you should go
watch it but but in effect basically she
tried to make an argument that you have
heard a gajillion times before but why
does your
right to free speech supersede a trans
person's right to feel okay with
themselves or something even the way she
phrased the question was a little
confused and and conflated but the thing
but the reaction to it
your answer was great but it was the
reaction the regular people watching at
home they were going this is nonsense
this is just abject but the only thing
that made it viral is the fact that she
recognized in the moment and what she
was saying was nonsense right you could
see the moment where you could see the
light go on briefly and she just went
wait what did i just say yeah and there
was no escape it was it was pretty it
was pretty grand yeah well the funny
thing about her argument is that it's
pre was predicated on the idea that
somehow people have a right to be
comfortable it's like that's just not a
right you have in life of all the things
you can say that you don't have a right
to in life being comfortable is number
one but you made that point you can
offend me right now so the thing is is
if you
if you're right to be comfortable
trump's my right to talk then i don't
get to talk ever
because i'm going to say things if i'm
actually talking i'm going to say things
if they're if they're profound things if
they're contentious things or truthful
things i'm going to say things that if
they don't disturb you are going to
disturb you and if they don't disturb
you there's someone that's going to be
disturbed about them so what's the
answer to that everyone can be
comfortable in the silence but that
doesn't also doesn't work because then
we can't exchange ideas we're not
comfortable in the silence we're
isolated and dead in the silence so it's
a completely incoherent perspective but
what does that tell you about just the
way mainstream media operates because if
you even even just in this last week
when i've read some of the pieces about
you that i think are so dishonestly
attacking the way you do things or even
you know i'll see there was an article
about you and it was like ben shapiro is
the cool kids philosopher or something
something like that
yeah and it was like well wait a minute
when did the cool kid be the smart
orthodox jew you know what i mean like
how did how did
like think about that and then you've
talked you've talked about the [ __ ] that
you went through when you were growing
up and all that stuff and then you don't
want to play with that regularly yeah
but but i can't imagine yeah
that wasn't exactly the same just like
small
and noisy exactly bad combination man i
could have taken care of both of you i
always say i was right on the middle of
of sort of like loser and cool so like i
actually did bully the kids below me but
i was bullied by the guys i was right
there keeps the world in balance there
you go but but
this idea that when they write the
article it's the cool kids philosopher
even though obviously you didn't grow up
as the cool kid or james damore is a
great one where they write articles
about him and they'll say the the tech
bro and it's like if you you both have
met james damore he's the shyest
quietest
decent
you almost literally have to drag
sentences out yeah yeah i i did an hour
and a half with him yeah but but he's
got a spine of steel though no it's
really something yeah fearless
despite what his disposition may
actually be but but what do you make of
that the way that they try to frame it
so they're already trying to undercut
you know what i mean before before you
even use it not to use your model but i
think that they're trying to impose
their own order on the chaos it's just
the wrong frame so well that's that's
what happened in the channel 4 interview
and it's it's sort of i was thinking
about the model that you were describing
with regards to your position on the
iceberg is that kathy had staked out a
position on the iceberg and i had staked
one out that was way lower like way
lower and what happened was she kept
questioning me at her level of analysis
and that just wasn't working because
that wasn't the level of analysis at
which i'm playing and well and i'm also
not playing although i'm trying to play
yeah you know what i mean because it's
better if you can play a little bit but
yeah i mean it sounds like wrestling you
had a lower base of gravity
and and i think that that gave you an
advantage well partly i wasn't trying to
win the interview right you know like i
and i don't try to win interviews i try
to go to an interview and have a talk
and have a discussion and see how it
goes and i don't have an agenda except
to not make a catastrophic mistake
that's agenda number one don't say
anything unforgivably stupid yeah but i
think that's i think that's the other
thing that makes all of this unique is
that if you actually meet and i mean
we've all met each other in this circle
now because it's really funny how life
works that way these circles are so
small but we know each other and we
actually talk with each other and all
this that's what i'm saying they're
forcing us together it's not even that
we're seeking each other it's also that
we all have a certain there's a certain
baseline
personality that we all have and that is
we enjoy the discussion we actually
enjoy the exchange of ideas and so when
you're on with kathy newman she says
stuff that like what what you were
getting from the right wing a lot was
how did he even stand this how do you
even stand this interview right how can
you get through half an hour of this and
you've done it and i've done it too and
the answer is because i sort of enjoy it
i mean this is what we do for a living
right
so the idea that that i don't enjoy
having conversations even with people
who don't get it it's not enjoyable
having your views radically
mischaracterized as as cathy newman was
trying to do to you that's irritating
but well that was so over the top that
it was hardly even irritating it's
mostly yeah
it was because i kept thinking well i
don't know who you're talking to but it
isn't me you know canadians who are
unvaccinated now cannot leave the
country
like what the hell why why is that and
i'm look i got vaccinated and people
took me to task for that and i thought
all right i'll get the damn vaccine
here's the deal guys i'll get the
vaccine you [ __ ] leave me alone
and did that work no
so stupid me
you know that's how i feel about it
it's like well now i have to get tested
for covid when i come back into canada i
have to get tested before i leave canada
now you know that might be the latter
issue that's an issue with the americans
and and so that's outside of the
canadian purview but the restrictions to
get back into canada are even more
stringent it's like why to get the
vaccine then if you're not going to
leave me alone
and i don't think the evidence that
unvaccinated or that vaccinated people
are less contagious let's say i don't
think it's very compelling yeah
so
why are the vaccinated all of a sudden
the unvaccinated all of a sudden a
danger
and i certainly don't understand the
push to get children vaccinated i think
that's i think that's
i think that's absolutely reprehensible
and i also can't figure out
norman deutsch wrote a piece in tablet
called needle points and one of the
things he pointed out was that if you
take the top 25 least trusted
institutions
um
in that group the most distrusted
institutions include
big pharma
and for good reason and he details out
the lawsuits that big pharma has had to
pay because of misbehavior on on their
part broadly speaking multiple companies
over the last 20 years and they're the
biggest lawsuits in american history
which is really saying something because
your court system is set up so that big
lawsuits are really possible right and
so i see the leftists all of a sudden
it's like big pharma yeah trust them
it's like what
wha what really
you guys
this is
i don't understand that at all like and
psychologically so what's going on here
it's like well i think the underlying
phenomena is something like phenomenon
is something like
well as long as it's for health and
safety
it's always good
and you know not to get conspiratorial
here but the same damn thing is going to
happen with the climate change push
absolutely they're already it's already
being reconfigured as well it's the
biggest public health issue of our time
it's like no i don't think so i think
overreaching bureaucrats are the biggest
health uh
what would you say the biggest challenge
to our health of our time we're
expressing something that was so
profoundly true
that we all know that maybe we can't
exactly get into the box that we can
just hand to somebody and say this is it
but that that was enough to move me i
think that's i think that's really the
argument you're trying to make that
you'll you'll bring to cambridge and
oxford and to dawkins and everybody else
yeah well and i would say in your
situation i know you're contemplating
fatherhood and it's probably the right
spirit to inhabit you as a
political commentator let's say a
cultural commentator so that's a good
way to reconstrue it you know to the
degree that you can be because you're
getting old enough now to that's the
right role you know you're not sort of
upward striving hero youth
it's that you're in that transition
and like benevolent father
that's that's a good one man
and there's no short there's no limit to
the number of people you can bring that
to
and there's no limit to how much good
that'll do in your own life and and in
relationship to your own children
so let me i i know you got to go here so
let me let me just ask you one other
thing just to tie all of this together
um
now looking back at these last couple
years the intellectual pursuits
obviously your health is better
uh at least to some degree you know
you're getting back out on the road
you're going to start touring and all of
this stuff
um
do you feel that that this is all really
making a dent do you feel like
that it's heavy and it's real and doing
something yes it's more real than
anything else i don't mean what i'm
doing specifically yeah but the sorts of
things that we've been talking about i
think the will to power just folds in in
its presence
it's so much more powerful well how can
it not be if it's actually the truth
how can it not be more powerful than
falsehood how can
what isn't there be more powerful than
what is there and why wouldn't we want
to align ourselves with the truth
you know it's really painful in the
short term because there's so much mess
you have to clear up your own and
historical mess even for that matter
but it's better than living in filth
and so
onward and upward and yes and i'm
optimistic man and i i've seen great
people in your country on both sides of
the political spectrum striving with all
their might to bring things away from
the insane edges
don't lose faith don't lose faith in
your institutions they're great
institutions
they're great institutions fundamentally
and remember we could have
everyone could have enough to eat
everyone could have enough energy
everyone can have an opportunity for
their children all of that
we have all of that in front of us we
have it right now we have it in the next
20 years if we don't
get
suspicious and paranoid and
and power mad and just especially
deceitful
if you'd like to see more honest and
insightful conversations with jordan
peterson himself check out our jordan
peterson playlist which includes every
interview i've ever done with him and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist both are right over here and to
get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell